and kevin durant right now with cassidy
kd 34 last night 26 tonight and your
first back to back since returning from
the achilles injury we even saw you
going up to steve nash and
asking to be put back into the game so
how close to 100
do you feel like you are right now i
feel like
i feel good well you get a win and
potentially another
superstar coming aboard the deal is not
finalized but what's your reaction
to potentially reuniting with your
former okc teammate james harden
our way to the to the deals finalized to
talk about it okay due to the reported
trade you guys only had nine players
out there and seven were in double
figure so how
do you sum up this team performance with
all of the drama and chaos surrounding
this team
i don't think there's any drama or chaos
i think the game is uh
you know just the game simply is enough
for us and guys is coming out there
enjoying playing every day
no matter what the circumstance is and
there's a lot going on throughout the
season throughout the endings world
right now but
you know this basketball is one thing
that everybody in this locker room
enjoys to do so
we came out here and played together on
both ends of the floor
and uh you know it was good for us to
get this win on the back to back it's
certainly a lot of challenges for the
players and your first time head coach
steve nash how how do you think he's
been dealing
with the start of this season he's been
doing amazing i mean it's a it's an
adjustment for everybody
and he's doing a great job this far
thanks katie
mike all right cassidy so durant will
have his old teammate back reunited
after the blockbuster trade with james
harden
as the nets improve now to seven and six
overall they're two and two on the road
nick's fault to five and seven overall
and two 2-4
here at home